ce sont des gens qui se sont qui ont
rebondi de façon remarquable après la
totale perte de tout ce qu'ils avaient
se promener sans qu'ils soient menacés
dans la rue pour eux c'est la vie
par rapport à l'espérance nous avons la
même
les membres de la famille de james et
mounir sont arrivés dans la région de
gloire en janvier 2015
originaire de mossoul et de bagdad ils
ont tout abandonné pour sauver leur vie
depuis deux ans la situation des
chrétiens d'orient s'est aggravée avec
l'émergence de l'état islamique
autrefois il est à un million cinq en
irak aujourd'hui il en reste moins de
350 milles quand j'étais à bagdad la
situation dégénérait il y avait beaucoup
d'explosions d'attentats quand on
sortait on n'avait aucune garantie de
revenir chez nous vivons en tant que
femme je vais une peur constante des
kidnappings il fallait vivre avec tout
ça au quotidien
nous n'avons pas décidé le sort s'est
imposé à nous avec l'arrivée de dèche
nous avons dû prendre une décision face
au danger
j'habitais un petit village chrétien
proche de mossoul et j'étais professeur
de mathématiques depuis 10 ans vous
savez cette décision a été très
difficile à prendre c'est comme
déraciner un arbre
gilles un des membres de l'association
des deux minorités d'orient les
accompagne depuis le début de leur ex if
c'est une famille qui se bat ils se
fondent ils font de gros efforts pour
s'adapter au mode de vie français et
pour acquérir les connaissances
nécessaires pour s'exprimer en français
ce sont vraiment des gens qui sont
reconnaissants à la à la france de les
avoir accueillis et ils veulent
s'intégrer visiblement ils veulent
s'assimiler même si on veut vraiment
l'intégration de ces personnes
il faut absolument qu un cac à moyen
terme court ou moyen terme
il arrive à trouver une activité
professionnelle quelle qu'elle soit ils
sont pas difficiles
oh
non
une partie de la famille occupe une
maison à la campagne au deuxième
ça va rapidement dans le loir et cher
une chaîne de solidarité lui a permis de
s'installer dans des conditions
matérielles descente je me suis dit je
vais faire parvenir l'information que je
suis prêt à accueillir une famille qui
vient et qui réfugiés d'irak et que la
maison que je souhaite mettre à leur
disposition n'est pas meublé il n'y a
plus rien donc si il avait chez eux
quelque chose qui permettait de la
meubler ce serait avec plaisir
partant d'une maison vide et en trois
semaines on a patrouillé avec une
remorque et une voiture dans toute la
région et en trois semaines on a réussi
à meubler complètement une maison qui
fait un peu plus de 100 mètres carrés
habitables skis et ski est pas si mal
ces instances pour eux je pense vous
pouvez demander ça à essence pour les
gens qui donnait pas ce que les gens
donnaient en se disant
donne pas pour n'importe quoi mais pour
une cause précise et le fait que ça pour
une cause précise connu à favoriser je
pense les dons mounir veut travailler
mais avant il lui faut apprendre la
langue française et les réfugiés
chrétiens irakiens arrivent muni d'un
titre de séjour de 10 ans et d'un permis
de travail délivrés par le consulat de
france installée à erbil dans le
kurdistan
les premiers jours ils sont un peu un
peu désespérée mais donc comme lice
c'est une entrée sortie permanente il ya
toujours des nouveaux donc ils
s'encouragent les uns les autres et sont
très motivés
vous le sentez ça oui on le sent on le
sent parce qu'ils ont beaucoup d'énergie
sont même le soir il travaille il
travaille au corps j'entends souvent
qu'ils travaillent en couple en famille
donc oui sont très très motivés et le
deuxième en huit premiers
dix mois comme j'étais professeur on
n'ira que je connais les méthodes
d'enseignement
je sais cela très bien je sais qu'à
prendre une longue cela n'est pas
évident ici dans cette école
ils nous apprennent le français à
travers des exercices pratiques
j'aime c'est son père vont passer la
matinée à la sécurité sociale
au quotidien les démarches
administratives sont souvent au centre
de leurs préoccupations et rythme la
majeure partie de leur temps dans
l'entretien que nous avons aujourd'hui
donc presque un an après l'arrivée de
ces personnes eh bien il va falloir donc
renouveler certaines choses et donc
madame me prévient donc pour moi c'est
c'est parfait ça m'évite de la galère on
peut le rencontrer parfois à courir
après les infos c'est très important de
faire au plus vite les démarches pour
eux en fin de compte et ensuite donc
pouvoir faire le dossier rapidement et
qu'ils aient accès à leurs soins
directement quand ils arrivent ici en
france c'est très important
on le fait pour toutes les personnes
mais ces personnes là en tant que
réfugié là l'urgence et c'est là où on
doit tout de suite percevoir cette
urgence car j'aime été garde de sécurité
à l'ambassade de france à bagdad
ici tout est nouveau pour lui ce que
l'on a vécu en irak c'était vraiment
très dur là bas on était au milieu de la
guerre c'était toujours la guerre qui a
commencé je vous le rappelle il ya quand
même plus de 20 en quechua est donc dans
notre vie au quotidien et bien nous
étions toujours très inquiet
en ce qui concerne mon père est bien son
ancienne vie en irak lui manque mais il
est là il nous soutient basse à cannes
et il est content car ici nous sommes en
sécurité surtout
l'événement ce mois d'avril est la
cérémonie religieuse de pâques dans une
église au bord de la loire
pour mounir et sa femme juliette c'est
l'occasion de partager leur foi
c'est important d'être là en irak
on a l'habitude de célébrer les fêtes de
pâques avec nos proches nos amis la
famille si je n'étais pas venu ici ce
soir
cela aurait été un grand vide dans mon
coeur
et
moi
oh
c'était un vrai bonheur pour nous de
d'avoir contact avec ces chrétiens qui
arrive directement d'irak et qui ont
beaucoup souffert
mounir nous raconter qui il avait une
maison sa maison qu'il avait achetée il
ya sept ans et puis un jour il est parti
est aujourd'hui sa maison b de la plus
lisse et d'autres qui sont à sa place et
peut être que sa maison ne la retrouvera
jamais
à
quelques semaines plus tard une des
responsable national de l'association
est venue réunir plusieurs familles
irakiennes pour évaluer leur condition
d'intégration
c'est à dire que là pendant qu'on va
faire le point sociales par rapport à
cheikh chaque famille vous aurez le
temps de réfléchir à ce que ça veut dire
la réciprocité du don c'est à dire que
les familles françaises vous accueille
je vous aide
monseigneur battu vous aide vous avez
d'autres personnes qui vous êtes qu'est
ce que vous allez faire en contrepartie
pas forcément pour ceux qui vous
accueille mais pour d'autres
elisabeth est inquiète sur la situation
générale des réfugiés seulement trois
mille visas ont été délivrés par les
autorités françaises depuis la vague de
migrants arrivés de syrie
les portes se sont refermées douze mille
dossiers sont en attente
nous avons des des familles dont les
enfants sont dont un enfant est mort par
exemple assassiné dans la rue on n'a pas
de réponse
il ya 70 % des dossiers qui sont soient
perdus soit sans réponse que c'est
désespérant pour ceux que ça fait qu'ils
ont espéré dans ce dispositif
on voit là leur secours et il ya
tellement de travail à faire que même
quand
dispositif sera fermé et il y aura
toujours quelque chose à faire pour eux
sinon pour d'autres
où
aujourd'hui james et mounir se rendent à
paris pour rencontrer le fondateur de
l'association des dominos rites et
dorian elish yako revient de bagdad où
il a accompagné une délégation de
parlementaires français
les nouvelles ne sont pas rassurantes
pour qu'elles l'irak reste unie il faut
un régime autoritaire qui imposera la
loi et c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va vers la partition de
l'irak
malheureusement c est réversible
irréversible et toutes et tous les
chrétiens d'irak vont essayer de trouver
une solution ailleurs sinon il faut
accepter le statut de citoyens de
deuxième classe là bas la plupart ne
refuse ce statut ils veulent y vivre
librement et vivre en lui leur thé
aujourd'hui c'est l'exemple mais malgré
toutes les difficultés et la différence
de culture mounir sait que l'avenir de
sa famille est ici dans un pays libre
l'intérêt est pour mon fils qui va
commencer une nouvelle vie
il va fréquenter les écoles françaises
car si l'on était resté en irak
il aurait connu la même mésaventure et
il n'aurait peut-être pas supporté ce
que l'on a su bien
il est sourd et allez paris
oui les gars une fille
il est sourd ou territory
tout à fait